as promised here is my review of the
Incredible Hulk and for those of you who
might be a little confused The
Incredible Hulk with Edward Norton is
not a sequel nor is it a tie-in to the
hulk directed by Angley it's a whole new
ballgame and a whole new story i thought
i should clear that up for you now
here's the review the Incredible Hulk
and as the Hulk is an Avenger this is
yet another movie that ties in with the
movie coming out The Avengers
so the Incredible Hulk was the story of
Bruce Banner played by Edward Norton and
a few years ago Bruce Banner was a
scientist he was working on something
for the military any kind of test is
something on himself what could go wrong
except he turned into an enormous green
rage monster and killed a couple people
that'll happen so what I like about what
they did with the Incredible Hulk is the
whole backstory of him becoming the Hulk
is all during the beginning credits you
find out in the beginning credits what
you need to know experiment happened
something went wrong he turned into the
Incredible Hulk he killed a couple
people he's now on the run I'm pretty
convinced that they didn't do it like
that the movie would be really cluttered
you have like a really slow hour at the
beginning of the movie showing how Bruce
Banner becomes the Hulk and it would be
like the angley Hulk boring but as we
catch up with Bruce Banner he's hanging
out in Rio de Janeiro he's trying to
find a cure for this Hulk thing that he
becomes you guys know the phrase you
know how he Hulk's out don't make me
angry you wouldn't like me when I'm
angry people make him angry big green
rage Hulk so he has these meditation
techniques you know these breathing
techniques that he uses he has a heart
rate monitor on his wrist it shows that
him dealing with this whole Incredible
Hulk thing is a thing that he deals with
on a daily basis I loved how they
Illustrated that and I love Edward
Norton as Bruce Banner he's a really
good actor first of all second of all
he's kind of a small frame guy I love it
when there's a big contrast between
little Bruce Banner and humongous
Incredible Hulk
acting talent physique he had it all he
is Bruce Banner and when he hooks up man
I love seeing that the armies chasing
after him some douchebags are trying to
kick his ass then he Hulk's out and he
starts throwing people like frisbees I
love it and as it turns out his quest
for a cure he has to come back to the
United States and which William Hurt
gets with of that and he's like no I'm
getting them where are the 50 cals movie
rushes Jude has a pretty awesome
mustache and he is after Bruce Banner I
think with Bruce Banner in the
Incredible Hulk there is bullying hurt
and William Hertz mustache you wouldn't
like him when he's angry I think his
mustache just gets bigger
becomes like the Lorax
something then we're all in trouble it's
the only thing that can take out the
Incredible Hulk the hurts - because as
he says in the movie as far as he's
concerned Bruce banners entire bodies
property of the US Army he really
doesn't give a about anyone he just
wants his Hulk weapon and that's another
thing I liked about the Incredible Hulk
I totally missed it when I first saw the
Incredible Hulk in theaters the
experiment that the US Army was doing
that Bruce Banner was a part of was part
of the super soldier project from World
War two
you know Captain America I loved how
they tied that in and of course Bruce
Banner has to face more than the US Army
he has to face Tim Roth who gets his
injection of the super-soldier formula
and becomes the abomination this is
actually my least favorite part of the
movie if I can say it like that I mean I
love seeing Bruce Banner
I love seeing him trying to cure himself
I love it when he Hulk's out and starts
wrecking Humvees my least favorite part
of the movie is when the big CGI Hulk
has taken on the big CGI abomination and
they're fighting and all their big CGI
glory not that I hate it or anything
like that it's the least interesting
part of the movie but it's still
entertaining I think that's pretty much
the best I can describe it I know the
Incredible Hulk is a really difficult
character to do because either it's
really boring because you want to show
the humanity of Bruce Banner or it's
just a big CGI mess because you want to
show The Incredible Hulk all the time I
can't imagine an Incredible Hulk movie
being better than the Incredible Hulk
with Edward Norton it's as good as it's
going to get and I thought it was really
good so in the end I will say I would
buy the Incredible Hulk on blu-ray I
know this because I bought the
Incredible Hulk on blu-ray proof is in
the pudding scenario I guess so I've
already asked you what your favorite
Avengers movie leading up to the
Avengers is so I'm gonna ask you your
favorite Avengers movie villain as in
the villain in Iron Man Iron Man 2
Incredible Hulk Captain America Thor
your favorite villain in any of those
movies comment below let me know mine
Loki love that dude he's gonna kill the
Avengers and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more
you